philippe muray re économiste philippe
huerre merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors pour bien comprendre
que dit précisément cette décision de la
cour de cass rue et dans quel contexte
elle a été prise alors ne partons pas
sur les détails trop techniques et
juridiques qui seront extrêmement
complexe ce qu'elle dit en fait ce
qu'elle dit la cour de karlsruhe a dit
il y a une limite au pouvoir de l'union
européenne et du nom repeignent réplique
notre pouvoir n'a pas de limites c'est
aussi simple que cela
alors pour revenir un petit peu dans le
contexte parce que pour que les
téléspectateurs comprennent la cour de
karlsruhe est chargé de faire respecter
le droit en allemagne ce la plus haute
cour de justice allemande
or l'allemagne est opposée à l'achat de
dette publique par la banque centrale
politiquement mais aussi juridiquement
c'est d'ailleurs pour cela on peut
revenir bien en arrière là dessus c'est
une décision constante en 1973 la france
a dû modifier qui préparait déjà la
monnaie unique a dû modifier sa loi pour
restreindre considérablement la
possibilité de la donc banque centrale
de financer l'état français alors plus +
peu plus plus près de nous en 2012 en
fait pour sauver l'euro pendant la crise
de l'euro vous devez vous en souvenir
draghi avait dit on fera tout ce qu'il
faut tout ce qui est possible pour
sauver l'euro et à acheter des dettes
publiques par centaines de milliards
d'euros il à la cour de justice de
karlsruhe avait déjà été saisie avait
dit qu'il y avait un problème il y avait
eu un ping pong avec l'union européenne
et finalement la cour de justice de
karlsruhe avait accepté mollement les
décisions de l'union européenne en
disant qu'il fallait des limites
or là on est à l'épisode 2 de cette
bataille donc huit ans plus tard et on
se retrouve avec la cour de karlsruhe
qui donne un ultimatum de trois mois à
la banque centrale allemande et à la
banque centrale européenne pour préciser
les conditions d'achat de la dette
publique
si ce n'est pas fait dans des conditions
propres dans ce cas là la bundesbank
arrêtera d'acheter de la dette publique
sur demande de la banque centrale
européenne et donc les conséquences en
sont très forte parce que c'est l'euro
qui pourrait sauter
à terme avec cette décision alors je
prends la chose très au sérieux ce sont
les mots de la présidente de la
commission européenne 1 quels sont
finalement les craintes de bruxelles les
craintes de bruxelles c'est qu'on limite
le pouvoir de l'union européenne alors
que les craintes de l'allemagne c'est
qu'on donne un pouvoir sans limite et à
l'union européenne dont vous voyez que
c'est quelque chose de très important
parce que s'il n'y a pas de limite au
pouvoir de l'union européenne dans ce
cas là il y aura une dissolution des
états de l'allemagne comme de la france
et s'il n'ya si l'union européenne a des
limites
l'union européenne a peur de pas pouvoir
fonctionner mais il faut savoir qu'on
est très hypocrite là dessus puisque le
traité de lisbonne disait l'union
européenne est une union sans cesse plus
étroite ce qui conduit forcément à la
dissolution à terme des nations voilà
donc on est dans ce problème d'ambiguïté
et une bataille de ping pong entre les
deux pouvoirs
on remarque que il ya un problème pour
l'allemagne mais il ya aussi un problème
pour la france l'union européenne
contrevient au droit allemand elle
contrevient aussi à la constitution
française l'article 2 c'est la
souveraineté nationale appartient au
peuple
l'article 5 c'est le président de la
république est le garant de
l'indépendance nationale
or on sait qu'on fait exactement tout l'
inverse la souveraineté nationale des
données à bruxelles en contravention
avec la s'ouvrait avec la constitution
française et la souveraineté populaire
en fait ne sert plus à rien puisque on
vote pour des gens qui applique
principalement les politiques de
bruxelles donc on voit que c'est un
conflit très important qui se met en
place qui est juridique pour l'instant
complexe mais entre le problème
jusqu'où va-t-on dans l'union européenne
est-ce qu'on laisse se dissoudre les
nations où les nations du foot ap
mais est ce que cette volonté de
bruxelles de sanctionner l'allemagne est
ce que c'est réaliste ça peut se passer
selon vous à mon avis c'est une partie
de ping pong on est dans une négociation
par médias interposés la courbe de 15
trous dit stop ultimatum on arrête la
chatte dette publique ce qui pourrait
menacer l'euro vraiment puisque c'est
l'achat de dette publique par la banque
centrale qui sauvent l'euro est là la
l'union europe la banque centrale dit
stop
l'union européenne dit stop ne faites
pas ça sinon vous aurez des sanctions
financières à mon sens ce sont des
négociations par médias interposés
l'allemagne je ne pense pas qu'elle
arrêtera le programme parce que sinon
l'euro ferait faillite et l'allemagne
aurait d'énormes problèmes
industriels donc la france
réindustrialiser ray je pense que
l'union européenne donnera probablement
une compensation à l'allemagne ce qui
permettra de sauver l'euro une fois de
plus et enfin pour conclure comment
comprendre que ce soit l'allemagne qui
est prononcé sept décisions de justice
c'est l'allemagne en fait qui
effectivement est le plus consciente de
sa souveraineté qui essaie de se
défendre de défendre sa souveraineté et
on sait que beaucoup de personnes disent
je pense que c'est papa à tort que c'est
une europe allemande
l'euro est une monnaie allemande s'est
pas du tout de monet adapté à l'europe
du sud donc c'est l'allemagne qui défend
ses intérêts et qui en profitera pour
pousser ses intérêts et c'est vrai qu'à
la fin attention parce que si jamais il
y avait un clash dans cette négociation
on finirait par une possible faillite de
la grèce et de l'italie
à moins que l'italie ou la grèce sorte
de l'euro avant est toute la question
est là il faut sortir de l'euro pour moi
en tant qu'économie jeudi il faut sortir
de l'euro avant que laure haut ne
s'écroulent sur notre tête voilà toutes
les contradictions qui sont mises seront
menées devant toutes ces contradictions
avec cette décision
merci beaucoup au feeling muraire
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste